[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host Paul and after Damon said keep
my wife's name out your [ __ ] mouth we
watched as a great banquet was held for
the two families after a food fight
viserys ended up going to bed where he
mistakenly told Alison about aegon's
prophecy just one problem she believed
that he was actually telling her there's
an aegon was the true Heir and that he
wanted him on the throne
[ __ ] is about to go down and that takes
us into episode 9. the trailer for the
entry is now out and throughout this
video we're going to be going through it
all frame by frame to talk about what
happens in it the clues for what's
coming next and also some of the Hidden
details that you might have missed
because of this there will be heavy
spoilers so if you don't want to
potentially ruined then I recommend that
you turn off now if you enjoy the video
please show your loyalty by hitting the
thumbs up button and make sure you
subscribe to join our house without the
way thanks for clicking this now let's
get into the house of the Dragon trailer
the king is dead
the
[Music]
door remains shut until we finish our
business
who you are or what you seek
I found out something you should know
seizure it is treason at the least
imagine yourself on the iron throne
[Music]
okay so the upcoming episode will be
called the green Council and as you can
probably guess this involves Alison
trying to place egg on as the king the
phrase green Council was coined by Grand
maester monkin in the book and the image
that accompanies it shows the Shady
conspirators all putting together
someone it will loyal to an Era and this
led to that downfall so the name green
council is fitting because it shows how
much Alison forced everyone to Bento
will in the books the speech with her
and viserys never happened and instead
she just did this because you wanted to
seize power however they've given her a
reason here and it makes more sense as
to why she'll stop at nothing to try and
carry out her late husband's apparent
final wish we open with an extremely
summer intro and have a focus on the
Iron Throne which now sits bare
symbolizing its falling King the entire
week after viserys's death was filled
with scheming and plotting from the
greens as they try to put everything in
place to make egg on the king typically
when a monarch died the bells of King's
Landing would be immediately ranked to
announce this however they didn't do
this due to potentially sounding the
alarm for those who are loyal to an Era
cut to Allison once more sitting in
viserys's spot on the council and he's
joined by her two loyalist supporters to
the left is Otto Hightower and on her
Rider sir Kristen Cole who sees her as
sparing him after the wedding shambles
because of this he feels like he owes it
at two hair and will do anything he can
to keep her in charge this includes
potentially killing Lord beesbree who we
later see in the teaser shouting about
how this is treason due to the books
having several accounts over what
happened we don't know for definite what
went on after he did this though we do
know that he indeed died according to
Grand maester Orwell he was arrested and
thrown into a cell where he eventually
died due to a cult whereas certain used
to said that Kristen Cole slit his
throat which we could potentially see
the aftermath of in the teaser a night
at one point can be seen cleaning their
blade and it potentially comes off the
back of just killing beespreet later on
we see swords being Jordan Kristen in
the council room and if you look in the
bottom left you'll see beesbury slumped
over you can't buy mushrooms other
Christian also threw him out of a window
onto some spikes in them out but either
way the character doesn't make it past
this meeting now this is known as being
the first Blood spelled during the lands
of the dragons and his death sets the
idea that no matter how high up you are
you can get executed for questioning
aegon is in the air it's possible that
Kristen also killed sir Harold who seems
to be the one drawing the sword on him
if you cast your mind back to episode 1
you'll remember that he was very loyal
to renera so it makes sense that he kick
off at this point Chris had ended up
being the leader of the king's God in
the book so they'll probably have him
kill him here and then take over his
place in the book after viserys dies
he's discovered by his servant and they
immediately go and tell Alison about it
she quickly calls together the council
and they start to put things in place
they keep his dad the secret until
nothing can be done to change aegon's
Rule and it looks like they're doing the
same thing here for example in the
source material renero went back to
Dragonstone whilst all this was going on
and she wasn't in the kingdom when her
father passed away this made it even
easier for Alison to keep things a
secret because she didn't send any
Ravens and thus rainera only found out
through word of mouth I believe that
she's still in King's Landing however
raniera might have actually gone back
home as the person we see with golden
hair fiddling with the door is rainey's
instead of her she's clearly locked in
this room as she can't get it open and
she might be held captive due to
supporting raniera last episode either
way the greens basically got everyone on
their side by killing Beast Bree and not
letting people out of the meeting until
they agreed aegon was the King this is
highlighted by the lambai Otto in which
he says the door remains shut until we
finish our business there's also a
strange character that we don't see the
face of and he's told that none can know
who he is and what he seeks looks like
he's in the king's God and that is one
of the higher ups because of the mission
that he's been picked to carry out we
don't really learn what this is either
gone to his face because his back's
turned but we can see some very facial
hair that could point to who it is now I
personally think that this might be one
of the cargo twins who we see later on
the teaser together they appear to be in
the same place that the fighting arena
is and later on we see one going to grab
aegon so I'm guessing this is what
they've been sent to do even though
these characters were twin brothers they
supported opposite sides and this caused
a mini Civil War in the household we do
see one of them swinging a sword in a
split second shot and potentially this
could be them fighting each other now
other theories involve this night go on
a Katrina and Damon however I don't
really think that's the case because
Damon would just kick his ass there
could be another mission involved though
and in the teaser we see what I believe
is aegon's bastard the book talks about
how he had one to his mother's maid
seven and also one to a woman on the
street of silk I think this is likely
the latter as we had the scene in Aid
where Alison made the servant drink the
plan T aegon's bastard could cause a lot
of problems and potentially his other
children could be pushed out if this one
came into the Limelight potentially Eric
could be sending after him to hush
things up before he becomes publicly
known now his brother was an ally to
renera and he might even end up helping
out his side because they look the same
they could do some twin hijinks and have
them disguise as the other to help or
hinder them either way I think the whole
thing with aegon's bastard will be told
to them by Lara strong who is he saying
that he's found out something
potentially mazaria found out the same
thing last week too and this is why we
saw Alison servant traveling to her in
the middle of the night you see this
servant being put into a cell at one
point so I'm wondering if she's the
person who discovers viserys and then
she's locked up the book talks about how
the person who discovered him was put
into custody however this was a man
whereas the servant here is a woman and
because of that they've gone [ __ ]
woke the bloody gone woke they've gone
[ __ ] woke I'm not having a woman on
the throne they've gone
calm down and she might just be being a
scorer to safety as it appears she has a
Targaryen child with her either way she
was the one wearing the clerk last
episode but in this teaser we have
several other characters we see amen
Dunning one to hide his hair and this
once more hammers home the idea that he
isn't opposite to Damon there are two
others in the trailer that wear this
including a one in the alleyway as
people run through and also one that
moves through the crowd these could be a
number of different characters and we
see one speaking to either Eric or Eric
at one point this appears to be a girl
and it could either be rain or a Baler
being smuggled out of the city at one
point we also see someone in a cloak
jumping over an edge and this could be
said person making their final escape
the shot of aemond also has a
distinctive set of steps and stones that
we can see surrounding him this also
looks like the same place that the
Cargill swings their sword and they're
doing it against the hooded figure
though he said it might be brother on
brother before this is likely against
Eamon and it might get to show how much
of a g he is now follows this is Laris
and it is important to bear in mind that
he was one of the first people to swear
loyalty to aegon he slashed his hand and
gave a Blood Oath at the council and
this slowly pushed the people into doing
the same thing and we see commotion in
the street and this could be for a
number of reasons aegon was publicly
announced and lots of people gathered to
see him however it could also be that
there's some uproar overranera we get
what looks like several ceremonies and
this includes Knights racing their
swords and people gathering at the
dragon pit this might be to show off
aegon's Dragon Sunfire and the Targaryen
symbol was also changed to Gold to
reflect this we also see aegon running
through the steps and this is likely the
character trying to flee from his duty
he didn't want to be king and when he
was told he was gonna be he was getting
a bj off a woman the book reads moreover
the prince refused at first to be a part
of his mother's plans my sister is the
heir not me he says in eustis's account
what sort of brother steals his sister's
Birthright only when sir Kristen
convinced him that the princess must
surely execute him in his Brothers
should hit on the crown did egg on
Weaver whilst any true born Targaryen
yet lives no strong can ever hope to sit
on the Iron Throne Cole said runira has
no choice to take your heads if she
wishes her bastards to rule after her it
was this and only this that persuaded
aegon to accept the crown that the small
Council was offering him insists or
gentle septon now this is likely why we
see him fleeing and why he's grabbed by
one of the twins the trailer that ends
with a voiceover of someone asking if
they could imagine themselves on the
Iron Throne I think this is likely
Alison to aegon when she's trying to
convince him to become king lastly we
see a crown being placed onto a green
cushion this is symbolic for a number of
reasons because it's being placed firmly
on a color that represents the high
Towers I also believe this is egg on the
conqueror's crown and in the book we
have an image of Sir Kristen Cole
placing this on Egan's head he wore one
laced with rubies and though they're
missing here we can see the spaces where
they'd end up sitting in the shot with
aemond we can also see a blurred out
figure to the left that's wearing the
crown down and this appears to be aegon
to the right is Helena and also a member
of the king's God and this could be the
moment where Kristen places it on his
head in the book Alison ordered for
viserys's Crown to be put in a vault but
this was stolen by a servant which my
time with the task that Otto is giving
to one of the knights either way aegon
clearly has chosen the conqueror's crown
for a reason and it's a very important
shot for the teaser aegon was of course
named after his great great great great
grandfather and viserys used to have
dreams about how he saw one of his heirs
on the throne wearing this Crown so the
prophecy came true but it's not good
news and this has major ramifications
going forward other shots include Lords
kneeling down in front of Arrow as he
stands near the throne to the left you
might notice Lord Caswell who was one of
raniera's loyalist supporters I feel
like he might get killed in the scene
too as he is executing the book for
refusing to switch sides Alison really
wanted her surrender and if she didn't
admit that aegon was the rifle Heir then
she'd have her murdered beesbree was a
perfect example of this and with viserys
out the way there's no one left to
protect here though he looked like the
Crypt Keeper you won't be wandering at
the steps anytime soon and thus she and
her family are now on their own I can't
wait to see how it goes down and with it
being the penultimate episode I really
think that things are gonna Mound up to
something big let me know your thoughts
below and hopefully I see you on our
next House of the Dragon breakdown we
are in a competition right now and
giving away three copies of the 11
thunder on the 15th of October and all
you have to do to be when the chance of
winning is like the video make sure you
subscribe and notifications on and drop
a comment below with your thoughts on
the teaser we picked the comments at
random on the 15 and the winners of the
last one are on screen right now save
that to you and message me on Twitter at
heavy spoilers if you want something
else to watch make sure you check out
our breakdown of episode 8 which will be
linked on screen right now you can over
all the callbacks to the books the
Easter eggs and yeah definitely head
over there right after this by the way
thanks for sticking through the video
I've been Paul and I'll see you next
time take care peace